[Musique]
tous les jours
c'est un univers assez particulier parce
que c'est une invitation au voyage
mais il voyage qui se fit en dedans j'ai
envie d'être surprise donc je mets pas
de limites
au contraire je me laissais complètement
de transporter ouverture d'esprit totale
mais surtout le coeur grand ouverts et
les oreilles grandes ouvertes
[Musique]
voilà on va y aller c'est dans quelques
secondes
je suis concentré à votre choix
[Musique]
j'entendais naya comme ça que je la
découvre je trouve ça extraordinaire et
jean avec sonny troupé avec vadeleux
[Musique]
extraordinaire bamoussa encore balussou
on
[Musique]
je suis contente j'ai passé un super
moment
on l'a fait et j'en suis fier parce que
c'est du boulot parce que c'est des
nuits blanches parce que c'est du
travail parce que fouilles quoi parce
que c'est des embûches
c'est tout ça et voilà faut les
surpasser faut en vouloir et je suis
contente
[Musique]